hey Doug Walker here I just saw an early
screening of best friends are in little
parentheses for those who don't know
this is the latest outing from Tommy
Wiseau and Greg Sestero except it's a
little switch instead of Tommy was so
writing and producing this it's actually
Greg Sestero
who wrote and produced this somebody
else directed it but this is very much
obviously kind of Greg story the plot
inspired by true events
this is spoiler free so I'm just gonna
give you the general sum up is sister Oh
plays a character who's kind of lost and
you know count down on his luck and so
he finds a very strange guy played by
Wiseau who seems very odd very strange
but he also seems very sucked into his
outlook on life he seems very positive
and he's weird and he can't quite get a
fix on them a finds him fascinating so
eventually this idea comes in where he
finds out that was character actually
has a lot of riches and they sort of put
together this partnership where they can
actually sort of take advantage of these
riches and sorry put a business together
and yeah sounds a little familiar
doesn't it I think you can kind of guess
what these true events are and I am so
curious to see what people think of this
movie I liked it I actually enjoyed it a
great deal this is one of those films
where I kind of I like watching it and
saying well now what was that now what
does this part mean what does this okay
this this is very different from the
room and it still has funny moments it
still has awkward moments but it's it's
shot very nice it's not a straight up
comedy it's not straight up drama either
is kind of a half and a half and it it
seems like one of the reasons it was
done was to see if Tommy can give us an
actual performance like a dramatic
believable performance and
because of this director very cleverly
working with the way Tommy talks and the
way he emphasizes different words and so
strange that the character they write
around him kind of works it's uh we're
in the room
you watch it and you don't believe
anything that he's saying you know it's
so bad and over-the-top and inputs
you know it just emphasizes weird things
here he does emphasize weird things but
you kind of believe that this weirdo
would you know like the best way I can
describe it it's kind of like watching
oh my god why am i blinking his name oh
I'm gonna cut so I remember it James
Franco sorry it's early in the morning
I'm sorry it's kinda like watching James
Franco - Tommy was so in the disaster
artist where it's like yeah he talks
weird and he sounds weird and he
emphasizes strange words but you're not
laughing the whole time at him you know
it's like you're laughing day sounds
kind of weird and a does stuff strange
but it's when he has to feel bad if you
feel bad when he has to you know feel
determined you feel determined and stuff
so it's it's very cleverly done in that
respect for the most part there's still
a couple times where it's just clearly
Tommy being Tommy you can tell there's a
few times where he interrupts somebody's
lying and and they go with it and it's
funny you know that one moment
particular when Cisneros character comes
up to Tommy's character and proposes
kind of kind of this scheme it's not
really that bad but that's a little bit
of a scheme um you know convincing Tommy
scared to go into it like you know it
I'm like nah this this is Tommy just
reading lines you know every once in a
while it just sounds like Tommy reading
lines particularly there's one moment at
the end where Tommy has to do something
really dramatic and I'm just like okay
that was the room that was the room time
me but you know who Tommy was so yes I
mean to get even a line out of this guy
to be you know kind of convincing you
know especially with that voice and the
way he talks and everything and the way
looks and all that stuff is impressive
and this is a film that really I'd say
about 90
percent of the time I actually bought it
but with that said it's not something
where I'm like oh this will start a new
dramatic career for Tommy Wiseau it's
like no the director and the and the
writer and Greg and everybody they knew
how to use with so they knew how to
write this character around him where
it's like okay this is just kind of what
this person is like and he's odd and he
makes masks at this morgue and stuff
like that but he's kinda bored but he's
also kind of upbeat and so yes this is a
very kind of very art house there's a
lot of slow-mo there's a last of this
kind of open to interpretation but
there's a definite story and the one
it's not really a spoiler but I think
it's good knowing going in this is not
the only part it looks like they're
building out that there's gonna be more
and the reason I tell you that is
because when I got to the end of this I
didn't know that I don't think a lot of
people know that and at first I was kind
of put off by it I was like what do you
mean this is heart what there's gonna be
another one wide and it just and it ends
on kind of this weird note and I it's
the only part that kind of got me
frustrated but then thinking back again
to knowing who these two people are in
the story knowing who wrote it knowing
that it's inspired by true events which
by the way if this is a totally
different story like a totally different
sure events like this actually happen to
other people and stuff like that it's
either a a major coincidence or B
they're clearly using it just to sort of
project you know their own kind of
thoughts you know add to these
characters but there's literally a scene
where they pick up a basketball and they
toss it back and forth fate they know
what they're doing so so there's lots in
a while a little wink like that but
majority of the people going into this
that know who Greg Sestero is know who
Tommy Wiseau is and because of that I
think you're gonna look at this and be
asking a lot of time well what does Greg
think of kind of everything that
happened what was that supposed to be
Greg Starr maybe what Tommy is saying is
kind of greats thoughts I think maybe
what Greg is doing is kind of what
it was doing in its it's one of those
things where it's I love a film like
this it's something where you kind of
watch it and it doesn't spoon feed it to
you 100% you still can't look at it and
be like what just blurs it just enough
you know I'm a big David Lynch guy I
like David Lynch films but I know other
people that hate David Lynch and that's
a very separate filmmaker and everything
but those people are just like baloney
it's just weird arthouse shift for the
sake of being weird arthouse so I
feel like there's definitely gonna be a
crowd of people that think that but when
I got to the end of this movie and I let
it sit and I thought about how it ended
and I thought what could they do with
this in part to knowing Greg Sestero and
Tommy was so and their relationship and
stuff where could this go after this and
I actually started to get really excited
I'm like actually there's there's a lot
of potential here with this set up like
I don't know exactly where they're gonna
go but there's kind of all these
possibilities and serve all these
different ways you could look at it and
film it and interpret in everything so
it it actually it when I let it sit for
a while and I thought about what they
could do I just got really excited to
see a part - I'm actually like super
super curious to see a part - now so
yeah so that's something that's good
knowing going in in my opinion it's like
the one kind of spoiler I guess you know
it's kinda like saying you know you see
Star Wars there's gonna be more it's
like you know it doesn't really ruin
anything but yeah it's it's one of those
films where it's it is taken more
seriously but there's definitely a very
comedic edge to it still
and there are still awkward moments in
both some of the performances and the
filmmaking like it's something at least
in the version I saw the frame rate
sometimes was a little weird like
sometimes it'll go in slow-mo and I was
just like well why did that go and so
like not even like super slow-mo like
there's a lot of times like then that's
fine but like there's like candles on a
cake and it shot a little bit in slow-mo
and I'm thinking why why was that shot a
little bit in slow-mo or they slow down
the frame rate or whatever so or sped up
I guess
now it just looks slow anyway whatever
they did um you know it's something it's
a hint distracting but because it's also
kind of this weird abstract way that
they're shooting it and editing it you
know you could argue that's part of the
style or if you want just look at as
like oh well that was weird goofy
filmmaking or that was a mistake or
whatever this is the duo that you know
kind of is known for that
so it's in my opinion it's kind of a
perfect circle of like all these
different elements of having good
filmmaking kind of awkward filmmaking
and good acting and awkward act it kind
of coming together and you know making
something that's both really kind of
both kind of blatant in what they're
doing but also raises a lot of questions
about what they're doing cuz I mean some
of the things they're implying or you
can take out of this you're kind of
saying wow are they are they really
admitting tonight are they admitting to
like you know and then maybe gray kind
of did this and maybe Tommy kind of did
this I mean not literally in this sense
by me maybe they kind of thought this
and maybe they're going through this and
I find it fascinating I find it a really
fascinating film to kind of think about
it's to me it's just the right amount of
just a right amount of giving you hints
and saying you know know what do you
think this is what do you think this is
but also not spelling it out too much
it's it to me it's kind of like what
mother could have been where it's like
you're kind of given these elements and
it's like okay now-now don't explain
anymore just stop but then they just say
at the end who the characters are and
they do this order that of course is
gonna be you know like from the Bible
and Mother Earth and stuff like that
it's like no you were doing fine I feel
like this one doesn't quite overstep the
bounds too much like I said there's an
occasional wink you know like I said
thrown the basketball back and forth and
stuff like that but I don't know I I
really like this I I really thought it
was interesting and made me really ask
questions about what they were kind of
trying to get across but in a good way
it's not I'm not sitting there
frustrated like well what are you trying
to say I'm actually like intrigued and
I want to sort of you know primeur and I
want to think about it more maybe that's
the thing it's a movie that invites you
to think more but I will say it kind of
only if you know who Greg sits there on
Tommy Wiseau R which like 95 percent the
people seeing this movie aren't going to
if you don't you probably see it as like
um weird art house film whatever you
know and then fright nothing twice about
but because really the majority of
people seeing this movie are gonna know
who Greg Sestero and Tommy Wiseau are I
think they are gonna be asking some
interesting questions like why did they
choose to have this character be this
way in this character be that way
so I really enjoyed it I thought it was
it was engaging it was still a story
where you kind of say what's gonna
happen you know you can't predict always
where it's gonna go and I'll even give
you a great example of a kind of of
Tommy's acting here there's a scene
where they're trying to trick on me
Tommy's character and he's looking at
this painted this thing that's a forgery
and my wife's watching this with me and
she goes oh no he knows it's a fake and
I said do you realize we just got
concerned because we were invested in a
Tommy was sober for is there any point
in the room when you're like oh no no
you're just laughing and how ridiculous
it is you know but with this one we
legit were like oh no like he knows so
it's one of those things where it's like
and I know it's like why are we praising
someone who you know actors do that all
the time and easily and in their sleep
and stuff like that but again there is
kind of this fascination to Tommy's
passion and in his weird
outlook and I feel like the the director
and sustar Oh kind of really honed in on
that and they hold it out on in the
disaster artist built the book in the
movie and I feel like the californian
out of here but it also kind of goes a
darker route to near the end it's always
kind of a darker route in this one which
I like - there's definitely sort of is
this dark edge to it but like I say if
you're looking for kind of a corny movie
- I mean
you'll get that as well there are
definitely moments where you know where
somebody might say a line kind of weird
or there's a little bit of like you know
calf awkward filmmaking and stuff I mean
for the most part it it flows pretty
well and it gets across I think what its
meaning to get across in terms of like
if you're supposed to feel the sad for
this character here you feel sad for me
if you're supposed to laugh at how weird
this character is you'll laugh at them
you know it's the right emotions I feel
they're trying to get are being
projected so yeah I really like it I
definitely say go see it especially if
your ass Estero with Soufan I think this
is you'll I think you'll really be
walking out saying like you know male
what was what are they trying to say
what are they trying to do and now I'm
really excited for part two I know
there's definitely gonna be people there
just gonna be totally turned off by this
because see it is too arthouse and you
know to you know to slow-moving or why
did you try to take it seriously but I
mean it's I feel it works I feel it's
because I know these people's background
and most viewers watching this know them
too I think it's something that's really
interesting and kind of leads to some
fascinating questions and that I'm
hoping I don't get the answers to like I
said this is the kind of movie where I'm
like no and and don't answer it you can
create more questions more kind of ideas
but don't answer them you know kind of
thing so yeah we'll see where it goes
we'll see what the next part leads to
and yeah I'm excited I really enjoy this
I highly recommend it if you're with so
or so stero fan I can't feel like even
if you don't like it you should still
see it if this isn't your thing like I
still feel like if you're so or some
sterile fan just like just go see it
anyway because like you're just gonna be
like man what were they are they up to
with this so yeah I definitely say go
check it out that's about it it's gonna
be on the big screen Phantom events is
doing it go ahead look it up see your
local theater might be showing it and
that's about it and I
talk to you guys later
you